Philip Philip of the Disney
hey you don't speak Swedish do you I'm
supposed to in Finland but I was skip
the class without super Swedish that's
when when I see these pictures I have
one one I have one question why why we
do everything for the cheeks for the
girls we were under the false impression
that girls would absolutely like
something like this but oh boy we were
wrong
yeah that's what we thought like 10
years back when we started doing this
nowadays we have a TV show but no chicks
has it all so anything to do with you
being you know finish absolutely I mean
look at the people of Finland we have
traditions like swimming in an icy lake
to sauna competition to wife carrying
competition or we even have a
competition of who can sit on an anthill
for the longest look each other in the
eyes to sit down there while you're
spending time at the summer cabin so I
think that's absolutely has something to
do with being from Finland so this is
not just cliches that we this is how we
imagine the Finnish are but it's it's
actually what they are I think all the
Finnish people have a little bit of a
douche on the inside of them so yes but
I also think all the Scandinavians I
mean we're all a little bit cuckoo in
our heads so there's all you all some
competitive people in a way oh yes
everything's about competing I mean your
friend does something you always gotta
top it and that's the beauty of it have
you have you ever been seriously injured
few times yeah last time a year ago we
filmed in the US for MTV USA and the
first week of filming he broke his back
I busted my tailbone my ankle and one of
us actually in the car new champ you
just saw he broke his ribs so we had
like you know a week of filming and and
we were all injured and in a hospital
and then we're looking at you know like
65 more days of filming so we're all
whoops were all crippled right now so
should we take some time off so we took
seven days off and kept on going how
long ago was this a year ago here we go
yeah you broke your back
broke my back I I intentionally crashed
an SUV to a semi-truck trailer and the
offer kicker and the impact was so hot
that it crossed one of my Iver the price
and I had to wear this funny-looking
like full upper body back brace for
three months and I got to lose some
weight how do you I mean when you come
up with these ideas and it's it's very I
mean the ideas are very original and
very colorful and they can make the
jackass boys seem a little you know
careful no I think I mean they're
absolutely not sell every one of them
really good friends with Chilean
officers and Pam and everybody but you
know that's one of the ways we look at
our stunts we everybody always looks at
the you know the nut shots or the
accidents that actually happened but
what we like to do is to come up with
the most unique ideas and something that
the idea itself would make the audience
go like wow how what in the world made
them think of something like that so we
always want to come up with the most
ridiculous kind of things to do like can
we do that backwards or can we do that
blindfolded or like that's not where I
walk into that bullring on stilts just
that's a concept it's so funny and
ridiculous and crazy it's something like
you would take it out of a cartoon or
comic yes it's like Tom and Jerry
exactly that's the modern day Tom and
Jerry and we you know we we never go and
do anything thinking that now something
might go wrong or now somebody's gonna
get hurt because well when we plan it
out most of the things look really good
on paper didn't realise not so good but
when you when you like doing a stage
show you have to do the same thing over
and over again yeah it's it's surprising
how many times you can take a beating in
a row I mean the stage show we do it's
you know a good 45 to 60 minutes it's
just you know high paced high energy
stunts little bit of stand-up comedy and
good music on it everything from him
putting on a bulletproof vest and me
shooting him with a shotgun in two but
that's only if they let us but like one
of the things that I guess it
I fell on my lap back in the days when
the guys made me to be the human
dartboard know that throwing darts at me
Anna yeah it's amazing how many darts
you can take how afraid do you get I
guess especially now that I'm older I
kind of I mean I walk on the side of a
cliff I get afraid right away I want to
walk away nowadays like I'm afraid of
heights or nowadays when I do stunts I
want to you know do it once I want to do
it properly like just hit the gas and
just blow hope for the best
it's like go big or go home but is it
like a kind of a Russian soul is it it's
a little bit about adrenaline because
that like the feeling you get right
before you do a stunt that's something
that you know I can't compare to
anything I've done it's probably
something like you'd get in love like
hundred times it feels it's exciting
it's funny how like nowadays like going
to a high place would make you scare of
the heights but it's actually when you
do the stunts and or you're behind the
wheel doing the jump you're not you
don't get that scare but if you see a
friend do it you get more scared for
your friend cuz it's out of your hat
here it's just hoping for the best that
everything goes well you like so you
have some kind of empathy or compassion
with her yeah never leave a friend
behind yeah I I noticed that we we
talked just before we went on the show
here and since we're both in showbiz in
a way you said it told me break a leg I
want to is that what you say before we
are still we said it wasn't somebody
broke like we're like oh oh we're not
saying it anymore
there are kids watching your shows I
mean it's it from from like 10 years and
up and I aren't you a little afraid that
they might try things that you know at
home well you know we have this thing
where we say don't do what we do do what
your mother tells you to do stay in
school
now but actually when you look at us
it's I mean hopefully we inspire people
because we just grew up and we had a
dream in Adam
risk or high school and then we just
started doing our own TV show and
produce everything and and that's why
for example our parents are really
really proud of us just because we're
actually able to make living with this
and we have a company and we employ a
lot of people and and you know aren't
they also very afraid but we the way
we've always done it is like we never
tell our parents ahead of the time what
we're gonna do we might give them a call
like afterwards saying I'll get this
what we were doing okay
you kinda up in the hospital but I'm
still coming for dinner I know my kids
too to continue watching as long as we
agree that they shouldn't try oh they
should not try it we're professors as
you could might absolutely start a
company but not like this yeah they
should hire someone from Iceland yes
don't you you don't want your daughter
to to try this thing it should be to be
too much a fan of the Dudesons to you
well I I prefer my daughter being
advance of all them instead of Justin
Bieber but thank you so much for being
here with us today
it was great having you here